HERE ONCE AGAIN IS CNN ROYAL
CORRESPONDENT MAX FOSTER.
>> Reporter: BRITAIN'S QUEEN
ELIZABETH II CROWNED AT
WESTMINSTER ABBEY ON JUNE 2,
1953.
THIS WAS THE FIRST TIME THE
PUBLIC WAS ABLE TO WITNESS THIS
SACROSANCT MOMENT.
ELIZABETH ALLOWED LIVE
TELEVISION CAMERAS IN TO CAPTURE
IT, IN A POWERFUL SIGNAL THAT
THIS WAS A NEW OPEN AND RELEVANT
MONARCHY.
ELIZABETH ALEXANDRA MARY WAS
BORN ON APRIL 21st, 1926.
IT WAS ONLY A DECADE LATER THAT
SHE KNEW SHE WAS TRULY DESTINED
TO LEAD AN EMPIRE.
IT WAS A FLUKE OF HISTORY, A
WORK OF SCANDAL.
>> A FEW HOURS AGO, I DISCHARGED
MY LAST DUTY AS KING AND
EMPEROR.
>> Reporter: HER UNCLE ABDICATED
TO MARRY THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE.
ELIZABETH'S FATHER BECAME KING.
SHE WAS THE ACCIDENTAL HEIR
WHICH ENTRENCHED IN HER A SENSE
OF DUTY.
SHE WAS DEVOUT, ALMOST SPIRITUAL
ABOUT HER RESPONSIBILITIES AS A
ROYAL EVEN BEFORE BEING CROWNED.
>> I DECLARE BEFORE YOU ALL THAT
MY WHOLE LIFE, WHETHER IT BE
LONG OR SHORT, SHALL BE DEVOTED
TO YOUR SERVICE AND TO THE
SERVICE OF OUR GREAT IMPERIAL
FAMILY TO WHICH WE ALL BELONG.
>> I SEEM TO REMEMBER HAVING
LISTENED TO THAT SPEECH AND I
REMEMBER VERY WELL -- CERTAINLY
REMEMBER READING IT NOT MANY
YEARS LATER, THE WAY SHE
DEDICATED HER LIFE TO THE
COUNTRY.
THAT WAS AN EXAMPLE WHICH I VERY
MUCH FELT WHEN I GREW OLDER,
THAT IS WHAT IT WAS ABOUT, YOU
DEDICATE YOUR LIFE TO YOUR
COUNTRY.
>> Reporter: ON NOVEMBER 20th,
1947 SHE WED HER CHILDHOOD
SWEETHEART, THE TALL AND DASHING
PRINCE PHILIP OF GREECE AND
DENMARK.
THE FOLLOWING YEAR, THEIR
MARRIAGE BORE ELIZABETH'S HEIR,
PRINCE CHARLES.
THE QUEEN LED THE EMPIRE BEFORE
SEEING ITS MANAGED DECLINE AS IT
BECAME KNOWN AS THE
COMMONWEALTH, AN ASSOCIATION OF
NOW INDEPENDENT COUNTRIES.
HER FIRST PRIME MINISTER WAS
WINSTON CHURCHILL.
DURING HER RULE SHE MET EVERY
ACTING U.S. PRESIDENT BAR ONE,
MEETINGS SHE ALWAYS PRIORITIZED.
>> SHE REMEMBERS LEARNING FROM
HER PARENTS HOW IMPORTANT
KEEPING AMERICA ON SIDE DURING
THE WAR AND THEN THE AMERICANS
CAME INTO THE WAR.
SHE REMEMBERS THE AMERICAN
TROOPS, V DAY, ALL THAT.
TO HER IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
PART OF HER GROWING UP.
>> Reporter: WHILST THE BRITISH
MONARCH HAS NO POLITICAL POWER,
ELIZABETH WIELDED IMMENSE POWER
AS A FIGUREHEAD AS DEMONSTRATED
IN 2011 WHEN SHE BECAME THE
FIRST MONARCH TO VISIT
NEIGHBORING IRELAND SINCE ITS
SEPARATION FROM THE UNITED
KINGDOM.
THEN PRIME MINISTER DAVID
CAMERON DESCRIBED THE TRIP AS A
GAME-CHANGER IN ANGLO-IRISH
RELATIONS.
A YEAR LATER THE QUEEN TRAVELED
TO BELFAST IN ANOTHER
SIGNIFICANT MOMENT OF HER REIGN.
AN HISTORIC HANDSHAKE WITH
FORMER IRA COMMANDER MARTIN
McGINNIS, A PUBLIC SYMBOL OF
PEACE FOLLOWING DECADES OF
CONFLICT IN NORTHERN IRELAND.
THERE WAS, NONETHELESS, A VERY
PRIVATE SIDE DO THIS WIFE,
MOTHER AND GRANDMOTHER.
STIFF UPPER-LIPPED IN PUBLIC AND
SO GUARDED THERE'S LITTLE
FOOTAGE TO SHOW THE SENSE OF
HUMOR SHE'S REPUTED TO HAVE
DISPLAYED BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
ON OCCASION SHE DID OPEN UP WITH
UNCHARACTERISTIC CANDOR AND
EMOTION.
THE QUEEN HERSELF MARKED 1992 AS
A VERY BAD YEAR.
>> IT HAS TURNED OUT TO BE --
>> PUNCTUATED BY SEVERAL FAMILY
SPLITS AND A FIRE AT HER BE
LOVED WINDSOR CASSELL.
THREE OF HER FOUR CHILDREN WOULD
DIVORCE.
CHARLES MOST FAMOUSLY AND THEN
THAT CRASH.
>> WE'RE GETTING WORD THAT THE
FRENCH GOVERNMENT HAS INFORMED
ALL OF US THAT PRINCESS DIANA
HAS DIED.
>> Reporter: THE ROYAL FAMILY'S
RESTRAINED RESPONSE COLLIDED
WITH A BRITISH PUBLIC CONVULSING
IN HEARTACHE.
ELIZABETH LEARNED A TOUGH LESSON
THROUGH ALL OF THE GRIEF.
SHE WASN'T MERELY A MOTHER OR
GRANDMOTHER, RATHER A QUEEN TO A
PEOPLE NO MATTER WHAT, AN
ENDURING IMAGE THE QUEEN BOWING
HER HEAD TO PRINCESS DIANA'S
COFFIN, MARKING A SAD PERIOD FOR
THE ROYAL FAMILY, BRITAIN AND
ITS RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
MONARCHY.
OVER MORE THAN A DECADE,
HOWEVER, PUBLIC FAITH IN THE
ROYAL FAMILY DID REBUILD.
THE QUEEN WAS VISIBLY THRILLED
BY THE SHOW OF SUPPORT FOR THE
ROYAL WEDDING BETWEEN HER
GRANDSON WILLIAM AND PARTNER
KATE IN 2011.
THEN THE FOLLOWING YEAR POLLS
SHOWED THE BRITISH ROYAL FAMILY
AT THE HEIGHT OF THEIR
POPULARITY AS THE QUEEN
CELEBRATED 60 YEARS ON THE
THRONE.
SHE USED HER DIAMOND JUBILEE TO
PRESENT A SLIMMED-DOWN MONARCHY,
ONLY THE KEY ROYALS PARADED AND
WAVED, A SIGN OF A MORE ECONOMIC
FAMILY FOR THE 21st CENTURY.
IN LATER YEARS, THE QUEEN
WELCOMED SEVERAL ADDITIONS TO
THE FAMILY, INCLUDING PRINCE
GEORGE, HER FIRST GREAT GRANDSON
AND HAIR TO THE THRONE BORN TO
THE DUKE AND DUCHESS OF
CAMBRIDGE.
PRINCE HARRY LATER MARRIED
MEGHAN MARKLE, THE ROYAL FAMILY
EMBRACING AN ACTRESS WITH
AFRICAN AMERICAN ANCESTRY.
IN TIME WELCOMING BABY ARCHIE.
PRINCE PHILIP RETIRED FROM
PUBLIC DUTIES IN 2017.
THE QUEEN CONTINUED.
SHE GRADUALLY SLOWED HER BUSY
SCHEDULE CERTAINLY IN TERMS OF
TRAVEL.
IN SEPTEMBER 2015, WHILST
OPENING A NEW RAILWAY IN
SCOTLAND WITHOUT CEREMONY OR
COMMEMORATIVE FIREWORKS, QUEEN
ELIZABETH II PASSED HER REVERED
PREDECESSOR, VICTORIA, TO BECOME
BRITAIN'S LONGEST REIGNING
MONARCH.
CONTROVERSY VISITED THE FAMILY
AGAIN IN 2019 AS THE QUEEN'S
SECOND SON, PRINCE ANDREW, GAVE
AN ILL-ADVISED INTERVIEW TO THE
BBC THAT MADE ALLEGATIONS OF
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT.
ANY HOPES FOR A QUIETER YEAR
AHEAD WERE DASHED WHEN HARRY AND
MEGHAN, THE DUKE AND DUCHESS OF
SUSSEX MADE A SHOCK ANNOUNCEMENT
AT THE START OF 2020.
>> THIS IS THE LAST TIME I'LL BE
WALKING INTO THE ABBEY.
>> Reporter: GIVING UP THEIR
PUBLIC ROLES AND DUTIES, THEY
MOVED TO NORTH AMERICA WITH A
MISSION TO BECOME FINANCIALLY
INDEPENDENT.
CRISIS TALKS AND ANOTHER
CONTENTIOUS INTERVIEW SOON
FOLLOWED.
IN 2021 AT THE AGE OF 99 PRINCE
PHILIP, THE DUKE OF EDINBUROUGH,
PASSED AWAY.
SENIOR ROYALS ATTENDED THE
FUNERAL, SCALED BACK DUE TO
CORONAVIRUS TO CELEBRATE HIS
SEVEN DECADES OF SERVICE AND
MOURN THE PASSING OF A DEVOTED
HUSBAND, FATHER, GRANDFATHER AND
GREAT GRANDFATHER.
ELIZABETH STOOD ALONE AS SHE
WATCHED HIS COFFIN LOWER INTO
THE VOIL VAULT IN WINDSOR.
BIDDING FAREWELL TO HER HUSBAND
OF 73 YEARS.
THE MAN SHE DESCRIBED AS HER
STRENGTH AND STAY.
SHE WILL BE REMEMBERED AS ONE OF
THE GREAT MONARCHS, ABLE TO HAND
A STRENGTHENED CROWN TO HER HEIR
DESPITE REIGNING OVER A PERIOD
OF TUMULTUOUS CHANGE.
>> CNN'S MAX FOSTER REPORTING
FOR US.
THANK YOU VERY, VERY MUCH.
>>> JOINING US, FORMER
COMMUNICATIONS SECRETARY TO THE
QUEEN, SIMON LEWIS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
I'M CURIOUS, HOW ARE YOU
REMEMBERING QUEEN ELIZABETH
TONIGHT?
>> WOLF, I'M EXTREMELY SAD, I
THINK LIKE NOT JUST THE COUNTRY,
BUT THE WORLD.
I WAS LUCKY TO WORK WITH THE
QUEEN FROM 1998 TO 2000.
IT WAS AN ENORMOUS PRIVILEGE.
I REMEMBER HER SENSE OF DUTY,
HARD WORK, SENSE OF HUMOR, HER
COMMITMENT TO THE COUNTRY AND
OBVIOUSLY THOUGHTS WITH KING
CHARLES AS WELL, HIS MAGISTERY
KING CHARLES BECAUSE HE'S LOST
HIS MOTHER, BOTH HIS PARTS NOW.
A VERY HUMAN MOMENT AS WELL.
IT'S A COMBINATION OF SADNESS
AND ALSO REALIZING LIKE ALL
GREAT INSTITUTIONS, THERE'S A
MOMENT OF TRANSITION AND THAT IS
HAPPENING IN FRONT OF OUR EYES.
>> CERTAINLY IS.
AS YOU WELL KNOW, THE QUEEN
SERVED IN AN INCREDIBLY PUBLIC
ROLE FOR SEVEN DECADES.
SHE WAS ALSO A VERY PRIVATE
PERSON.
CAN YOU SHARE WITH US A
TREASURED MOMENT YOU HAD WITH
HER?
>> WELL, THE EXTRAORDINARY THING
ABOUT THE QUEEN IS, ONCE YOU
WERE A CLOSE ADVISOR -- BEFORE I
WAS APPOINTED TO BUCKINGHAM
PALACE, I HAD NEVER MELT A
MEMBER OF THE ROYAL FAMILY.
ONCE YOU WERE THERE, YOU WERE
TREATED AS A MEMBER OF THE
FAMILY.
THE FIRST TIME I WENT TO
BALMORAL AND ONE OF THE FAMOUS
BARBECUES AND A RANGE ROVER
DROVE UP AND I WAS ASKED TO
DRIVE.
HER MAJESTY GOT IN AND SAT NEXT
TO ME.
I REALIZED IT WAS HER MAJESTY
AND MYSELF DRIVING DOWN TO THE
BARBECUE.
I'M VERY GLAD I HAD MY DRIVING
LICENSE THAT NIGHT.
I REMEMBER AT THE PALACE
PRESENTED A PARTICULAR PROPOSAL
TO THE QUEEN FOR A PARTICULAR
PROJECT WHICH I THOUGHT WAS A
GREAT IDEA.
SHE LOOKED AT IT AND SHE SAID,
SIMON, THAT'S FAR TOO GRAND FOR
US.
I THINK THAT COMBINATION OF